dans les collèges et lycées vous l'avez
entendu une minute de silence a été
observé à 14h et les cours annulés
jusqu'à 10h objectif permettre aux
enseignants d'échanger de préparer le
retour des élèves un retour dans une
ambiance pesante qui s'est accompagné de
mesures de sécurité renforcé voyez ce
reportage à tour de Lucas Chopin à la
demande de Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Éducation
nationale je vous prie d'observer une
minute de silence en hommage aux
professeurs et aux agents techniques
victimes du terrorisme
émotion et recueillement ce matin dans
nos écoles 3 jours après l'attentat
d'aras qui a coûté la vie à un
professeur une minute de silence a été
observé chez les élèves du lycée
jean-monet à Joué les Tours ce matin
c'est la peur qui dominait aujourd'hui
je voulais pas retourner en courant par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé ouais
ouis moi non plus je voulais pas revenir
j'ai pas le choix mais bah avec les
événements je trouve il y a un peu de
terreur envers les élèves ils ont peur
d'être pas assez peut-être protégé on
sent quand même un peu en danger par
rapport aux événements c'est que ça peut
arriver à n'importe quel moment c'est
assez soudain du coup c'est assez
inquiétant c'est comme un sentiment de
peur qu' y a derrière parce que bah à
tout moment bah ça peut recommencer on a
une certaine inquiétude à venir au lycée
on sait pas comment réagir on se pose
tous des questions sur les mesures de
sécurité et tout ça donc on est un peu
perturbé pour assurer la sécurité des
établissements scolaires plusieurs
mesures ont été prises renforcement des
protocole de mise en sûreté contrôle de
l'identité des personnes et contrôle
visuel de leur sac côté enseignant les
personnels se sont réunis avant les
cours ce lundi pour évoquer les
nouvelles mesures de sécurité mais aussi
partager leur émotion c'est un vrai
traumatisme je suis moi-même enseignant
j'étais euh avec des des collègues ce
matin euh en salle des professeurs euh
c'est très difficile d'être indifférent
à à l'attaque à l'agression à au crime
effectivement d'un enseignant c'est
quelque chose que qu'on ne peut pas
accepter euh c'est euh voilà on a dû
accompagner et je le comprends
pleinement euh l'émotion des enseignants
ce matin la première ministre ellisabeth
borne a élevé le plan Vigipirate au
niveau urgence attentat et appelle tout
comportement suspect à être
signalé